في هذا المركز المجتمعي الكردي في
جوتنبرج ، يشعر السكان المحليون بعدم الارتياح لأنهم قد
تم جرهم إلى مفاوضات الناتو السويدية
بالطبع نحن خائفون من القول
إننا عالقون في المنتصف تقول
بعد أسابيع من طلبها أن
خطط السويد للانضمام إلى الناتو تظل في طي النسيان
بفضل تركيا التي  الادعاءات بأن
الانفصاليين الأكراد يعملون من هذه
الشواطئ وهذا شيء تنفيه السويد ،
لكن أنقرة لا تزال تحاول تسليم
العشرات من الأشخاص بمن فيهم أعضاء
في البرلمان السويدي ، ومعظمهم
ليس لهم صلات بتركيا على الإطلاق مثل
الرجال في هذه الغرفة المولودين في إيران
والعراق.  يقول: إذا وقعت
وتريد الحرية ، فأنت إرهابي يقول
كريم رسولي أن هذا ليس صحيحًا
بغض النظر عن المكان الذي أتيت منه
إذا وقعت ، فستواجه مشاكل
مع تركيا يقول باهيا
من المنظور التركي إنهم "
نقول ، انظروا إلى السويد ، تريدون الانضمام إلى
تحالف عسكري حيث نحن
أحد الأعضاء الذين نعتبر أن هذه المجموعات
تهديدات للأمن القومي يفعلون
نفس الشيء  مطالب على الدول الأخرى الأعضاء في الناتو ،
لكن ليس لديهم نفس النفوذ كما
يفعلون الآن ، حيث أن السويد تنتظر
المجيء في
السويد هي موطن لما يقدر بنحو
مائة ألف كردي يمثلون ما يقرب من واحد
بالمائة من إجمالي سكان هذا البلد
وهناك تعاطف واسع النطاق
مع  قضيتهم تعني أنه
مع استمرار تركيا في تعطيل
محاولة السويد لحلف الناتو ، كان هناك شعور متزايد
بالاستياء أن السويديين قد انقسموا تقريبًا بشأن
الانضمام إلى الناتو قبل أن تقرر الدولة
الاشتراك ، وبين الأكراد هناك
وجهات نظر مختلفة أيضًا
في هذا الاحتجاج المناهض للناتو فوزي بابان
يقول الكرد العراقي إنه ضد عضوية الناتو في
ميدلاند
العراق ، انظر إلى ما فعله أعضاء الناتو في
بلدي ، وقال إنهم
دمروه تمامًا ، فأنا متأثر بشدة
بهذا الأمر منذ أن جئت إلى هنا
كأسير حرب أصابها هنا.
الأتراك في مجموعة العمل الذين يقاتلون من أجل
حقوق الأكراد في السويد يؤججون أيضًا
غضب أنقرة ، هذه هي جائزتي الكردية
التي قدموها لي عندما كنت في السجن
بعمر 74 عامًا  المرشح التركي المولد لجائزة نوبل للسلام ،
راجيف زاراكولو ، هو الآن مواطن سويدي لكنه يقاوم
تسليمه إلى تركيا بسبب كتاباته
دفاعًا عن الأقليات هناك أشعر
بمضايقات.  للعثور على الكلمات
لتعريف هذه الغرابة ،
قررت السويد الانضمام إلى
الناتو لجعل سكانها أكثر أمانًا بعد
غزو روسيا لأوكرانيا ، ولكن بالنسبة لجزء من
شعبها ، فإن عملية
الانضمام تجعلهم يشعرون بأي شيء سوى
نينا دوس سانتوس سي إن جوثنبورغ السويد